hello my name is Kasia converse kheh and
I'm a developer for Radian statistics
I'm going to present some of the new
features we are at full version 11 metal
has four parts
so version 11 adds numerous improvements
and extensions for our ability and
statistics functionalities including new
and improved hypothesis tests
performance improvements for descriptive
statistics and derived and formula
distributions and new improved random
processes support including parameter
estimation inhomogeneous Poisson process
and the random point sampling our trim
level now provides a burning house and
the apps fully test which is a test for
multivariate normality so then create a
sample from the multi normal
distribution and then use the bearing
house has a test to create hypothesis
test data extract p-value or extract the
test data table that has the value of
the statistics as well as that we value
the test statistics is invariant under
affine transformations of the data a
random point allows to sample points
over a given region again for example
sample over a convex polygon we can
sample points over an implicit region
and we can also sample over a country
polygon there is new process
eleven which is inhomogeneous Poisson
process this is a Poisson process with a
time varying rate and the probability
density function of the process slice at
any time T is Poisson distributed we can
simulate the path of the homogeneous
Poisson process and plot it also version
11 supports the estimation of continuous
time random processes over irregularly
sample data here we have example or time
series of the stock prices I can check
that the time stamps of the stock price
data are not uniform and an assumed that
the log price follows a fractional
Brownian motion process and estimate the
parameters using estimated process
version 11 adds improvements to time
series processing throughout the
framework the time series objects are
now produced and accepted by many
functions in the system we have better
data and quality support in time series
it is possible to directly apply
functions to a time series and perform
arithmetic also a version that has
better support for irregularly sampled
time series and final control from
mapping using moving windows over time
series director automatic here we have
example of two time series of stock
prices we can simply add them and plot
the sum can calculate the ratio of two
time series directly and we can also
directly apply a function to one of this
time series can smooth and fin the time
series of daily stock prices using the
moving map we use the moving map of
medium to compute the moving medium you
can see that the data has been smoothed
can compute the moving the free months
moving median in increments of one month
and comparing the path lengths for each
outcomes and the data we see that when
we calculate the moving median
increments of one month the data is not
only small but also faint and compared
the results
also we can compute the three months
moving median in increments of one
month's placing the windows on the
specific date so let's do it for the
first of each month and we see that the
first full three months window on the
first of the months appears only in May
since this time series it's one of
silverstein shorter than the previous
one
you can see that values are different
and from the other output because there
are different windows and then we can
plot the data against this smoothing
version 11 supports quantities across
the probability and statistics
functionality we have support for
quantities and descriptive statistics
and visualizations and support for data
with units in parametric and
nonparametric models and you can compute
probability and expectations of
quantities there is a new object called
quantity distribution that allows us to
store the distribution of the magnitudes
and the units of quantities it is
possible to extract quantity magnitude
and quantity unit just like for the
quantity also it can convert quantity
distribution to a distribution in new
units using unit convert and find the
expectations I can simulate from
quantity distribution a single
simulation it's a quantity and the
vector of simulations is given as a
quantity array and we can look at the
PDF using histogram the quantities can
also be input into the parametric
distribution as the parameters if they
make sense so in this situation we
define by normal distribution with means
and standard deviations giving in metres
in kilograms for each component and
correlation coefficient is unitless and
if this input makes sense then it's
going to be automatically converted to
quantity distribution can have this
quantity distribution compute
probability they can also compute the
distribution of the body mass index
using transform distribution calculate
the mean and also simulate and study the
PDF
for estimation have looked at the
example of the weather data and you can
see the values on the histogram you can
extract the values and interpolate the
missing values and then find the
parametric estimate with estimated
distribution and also find a
nonparametric estimate using smooth
kernel distribution and then compare the
estimates against the histogram version
11 introduces support for random
matrices can generate matrix variate
estimate the properties and compute the
limit distributions have Gaussian and
sample circle and symbols which are tan
inverse we heard matrix distributions
matrix normal and T distributions and
also limiting distributions of eigen
values which include Wigner semi circle
Tracy widom and Marchenko pasture
distributions the circular and symbols
are families of unitary matrices of
distributions that are involved under
different unitary transformations in
version 11 we have free assembles circle
real unitary and orthogonal matrix
distribution the matrices from circular
real and symbol can act as rotation
operators for vectors so you can sample
a thousand of such matrices and then
create a random rotations of the vector
0 0 1 check that all the points are
lying on the sphere and then just plot
them the Gaussian and samples are
families of normally distributed random
matrices with distributions that are
invariant under different unitary
transformations we have three certain
samples Gaussian orthogonal unitary and
selected matrix distribution matrix
elements of the Gaussian orthogonal and
simple follow a mixture of two normal
distributions so I create a sample of
matrix elements from Gaucher orthogonal
matrix distribution create a model which
is a mixture of two normals
estimate and then compare to the PDF
matrix
for distribution it's a new function
that provides a convenient access to
compute and sample the distributions of
the properties of metric distributions
for example we can find distribution of
the determinant for two by two matrices
from Gaussian orthogonal ensemble so
define the distribution of a determinant
using matrix property distribution
generate a sample and visualized using
histogram also we could estimate a
spectral density for Gaussian unitary
and sample so define the distribution
for the spectrum and then plot the
histogram tracy we don't distribution is
the limiting distribution of the scaled
largest eigenvalue of a radio match
random matrix belonging to a gaussian
and symbol there are three classes of
tracy Widom distribution let's define
the scaling function eigenvalue
distribution using matrix property
distribution generate a sample for the
dimension 250 and then plot the
histogram against the PDF of tracy widom
distribution Marchenko pasture
distribution is the limiting
distribution of the eigenvalues of a
Wishart matrix as the matrix dimension
and a number of the list of freedom
satisfy certain conditions so here we
have to find the degrees of freedom and
the dimensionality and create a
distribution of the matrix property
distribution simulate eigenvalues from
such a matrix and then compare the
histogram to the PDF of Marchenko
pasture distribution thank you for your
attention